monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
après l'attaque inacceptable contre le
domicile du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
intervenu dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche je souhaiterais réaffirmer au
nom du Président du Sénat notre soutien
déterminé à l'ensemble des élus pris
pour cible ces derniers jours
nous nous associons à l'appel lancée par
l'association des maires de France aura
semblement ce jour devant toutes les
mairies de France en marque de ce
soutien aux élus de la République et
pour condamner les attaques contre les
symboles républicains que sont nommeries
nos écoles nos bibliothèques par
ailleurs nous avons appris avec beaucoup
d'émotions la mort au cours de la nuit
d'un pompier de 24 ans en
Seine-Saint-Denis en luttant contre un
incendie dans un parking au nom du Sénat
tout entier je souhaite lui rendre
hommage et présenter à sa famille ainsi
qu'à ses collègues de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris nos
condoléances les plus attristées je vous
propose d'observer un instant de
recueillement